las vegas is a town filled with unique
and odd jobs and two of them are chris
angel's a mystica at planet hollywood
now joining us now are tatiana who is
are you you're art escape artist or not
an escape artist i am his assistant
an acrobat an aerialist okay because it
said escape artist but you've done
escape artisting before in the past
correct and then we have mike hammer who
is that not an escape party magician you
do it all my friends yeah i do so
tatiana how long you've been working for
chris about 10 years now and what does
your your what does your typical night
entail when it comes to your job
you well in the morning you have to work
out get prepared everything and then you
know you do your makeup and you warm up
say hello to everybody especially mike
the funny guy over here he gets us going
and then we perform and then mike you
step out there and you move the crowd
first yeah antagonize them uh get them
riled up for the show
pick on them a bit yeah it's great it's
a fun job it is fun yeah now what did
you guys want to be growing up i find
this so fascinating growing up what did
you want to be and look what you're
doing now i wanted to be a performer
this was it you knew it i knew what i
wanted to be since i was 10 years old
hey do you mike i've always wanted to do
this yeah ever since i was i wanted to
be a plumber
and
now why does no one believe me when i
say that because you're a comedian
that's great hey plumbers in my eyes
plumbers are angels you got a leak you
call a plumber who else is going to fix
it you can eat those formulas no you got
it yeah no i didn't want to be a plumber
it's a noble profession what's the
oddest thing that has happened during
the show you're up there performing do
you see something crazy in the crowd or
stunt grows wrong what's the oddest
thing
we did have one night where uh the
escape are the real escape artist uh
holding his breath underwater he had
some struggles uh so you know he
actually a tribute to houdini
so he gets in it's a
caged a water tank basically and that's
he's locked up chains all around him and
then the
chains are put on the trunk and uh he
had trouble breathing that day because
it's legit he healed his breath for like
five minutes and uh
he struggled chris came in saved the day
so it was really cool
that night he's the man yeah so if
someone has never seen the show before
what's the show about
the show is generally about how
christopher became chris angel um it is
called a mystica it is um i mean secret
garden
it means the the secret place okay
so it's it's the trials and tribulations
of life
um it's a show for everybody everybody
that goes through the their life stories
how they became
successful or happy
it's a great show i got to wrap it up
here
what's chris angel like we've met him a
couple times he's a great guy yeah i i
was friends with him before i was in the
show and uh yeah he's great he's a lot
of fun and yeah he plays pranks too on
people because you you actually you're a
magician as well right like yeah yep you
slide a hand or anything slate of hand
and nice watch illusions like the watch
is missing oh see you're good the hand
takes away you're thank you guys so much
for joining thank you associates thank
you and you can check out a mystica the
mind freak prequel created by chris
angel and franco dragon wednesday
through sunday at the chris angel
theater inside planet hollywood the
shows they start at 9 30. rocky over to
you thank you jc and speaking of